je vous prépare la chakhchoukha un
traditionnel qui n'en est spécifiquement
celles de tunisie cherche tout cas déjà
c'est un mot berbère que veut dire
mélangeait chaque un sauté de légumes 2e
sauté de légumes venus de l'afrique du
nord est une savoureuse manière de
revisiter une recette à base d'oeuf
pocher on le sert lors du brunch ou
soirs de semaine ça représente quoi se
plaint là pour vous pour l'étudier on
aime ça le quelque chose d'épicés de
piquant et c'est sûr c'est un plat
millénaire alors sa une un ca du
caractère et tous les tunisiens dorsale
a nice c'est la recette de sa grand mère
et de sa mère qui l'a maîtrisé à force
d'appels téléphoniques
je sortais d'or appelé ma mère lui dire
quoi faire et nous donnait des petits as
tu sais tout ça comme le fait sa
grand-mère douja à nice cuisine
exceptionnellement pour nous sur un
canot aujourd'hui on va faire la façon
traditionnelle au sur du charbon de bois
alors on commence par l'huile d'olive et
6 ans n'a de l'ail du gros sel de mer
mais on veut ajouter du mortier de votre
grand mère
voilà c'est ça l'histoire des familles
des genres a même une valise de tunisie
avec l'inde épices commence la recette
on met des oignons des poivrons et
quelques tomates oeufs vous ajoutez des
merguez
oui ok on pourrait le faire mais j'ai
dernier où on peut le faire végétarien
oui on fait bien sauter ça on ajoute
nous et fils curcuma aprica alyssa
maison s'agitent au savoureux mais la
voix la chakhchoukha été introduite en
orient avec les juifs d'afrique du nord
quand ils sont partis en orient ils ont
emmené sa dans leurs valises
et c'est un repas quand la maman elle
s'ennuie de concocter des petits repas
elle improvise almées tous cas la dent
au frigidaire comme légume et elle fait
une chute chocat s'est impliquée
relativement économique aussi est très
économique c'est le plat on peut dire
même le
du pauvre là on est arrivé à l'étape où
on pourrait mettre les ont fait passer
directement dans le réchaud en
s'assurant que le jaune reste cool et si
vous faisiez goûter votre chat chukka à
votre mère qu'est ce que dire ce que
furent de son petit garçon
c'est parfait moi j'ai une proposition à
vous faire un collègue à un coin de rue
d'ici qui fait une version de bourgogne
2 poché dans le vin on pourrait
peut-être aller le rencontrer frédéric
le chef d'ubs le raisin nous propose une
vieille recette sur le thème de l'oeuf
poché comment vous l'appelez cette
vieille recette là à aller je me rêve
c'est une façon de manger les restes en
du bourguignon du boeuf bouilli oui
absolument
qui reste toujours beaucoup trop de
sauce tout le reste en dessous ce qu'est
ce qu'on fait avec mais en se classant
9e dans le poche et voilà le shu pei
près ou au pire le dîner du lendemain
cette recette aussi que je revisite
c'est très drôle que ça m'a replongé
dans mon enfance mon grand père avait
l'habitude de nous faire salle dimanche
et puis ça va beaucoup de souvenirs de
nostalgie pour moi
c'est vraiment comme dans le temps de
pâques un peu à bon compte et c'est le
printemps mais pas tout à fait encore et
un peu frais et puis on a besoin de ce
genre de plats ration comment on peut
décrire ce plat laisse un plat de en a
beaucoup trop de sauce
on en a marre de manger du riz de dante
manger les pas et qu'on met d'autre
chose faute d restant des bourguignons
ont recréé une sauce dans une poêle bien
fumantes
avec un petit peu de beurre on va faire
suer notre échalotes
on ajoute le lardons pour que ça donne
du goût au fond de la poêle ont des
glaces avec une bouteille met aucune
toute la bouteille oui car comprend un
petit vin pour la cuisson pas trop
dispendieux on dresse avec nos petits
navets taillé en frites haute aux
embauches l'oeuf à la dernière seconde
et ensuite on la nappe avec notre
réduction c'est tout simple
asim amr ali foyer sans fils traverser
la rue kuhn chakchouka pour la faire
goûter à son voisin français
qui aurait cru que de saint-cloud
gaucher a l'air vous attabler autour de
plats aussi beau que plan le avec le
croqueur d'une averse est très très bon
alors hop il faut qu'il soit vraiment
cool ans comme celui que monsieur a fait
bravo
là je suis heureux on va bouter métrage
l autre couleur
aujourd'hui oui lors bien qu'il
traversait un exter année là ces deux
membres du très savoureux bruno et merci
d'avoir apporté dans vos bagages et
recettes de vos grands-pères et
grands-mères
[Musique]